Foreign Secretary Jeremy Hunt has told
around there'll be consequences if it
detains British foreign nationals for
diplomatic game he's met with his
Iranian counterpart on his first trip to
the country today to discuss a range of
issues
they included appealing for the
immediate release of British Iranian
mother nothing in Zhu Gary Ratcliffe
joined by nursing his husband Richard
hello to you Richard he we we know that
the Foreign Secretary has spoken
extensively to you what is the latest
that you're being told ahead of this
visit so I met with his team on Friday
and to talk about what what he was going
to do and my great plea to him was
please be as strident and as clear as
possible and I think you know straight
forward speaking is the way forward in
this situation and in fairness to me has
been very clear and their public
statements he's made around listen
please don't use people like Nazneen as
diplomatic leverage is as clear as it
comes so I'm grateful he's done it and
grateful for him taking a clear stand in
terms of what else we've been briefed
well he his team was saying that he was
gonna meet with the foreign minister he
was gonna meet with security people
about the nuclear deal and he had
another couple of meetings he was trying
for the key one for us was we were
hoping that he was going to be able to
meet with someone from the judiciary or
the Revolutionary Guard since those are
the people that are holding mezzanine
and to have a sort of behind the doors
meet him to discuss what it is that they
want and why there's this problem and I
think the other meeting he was hoping
today was to meet with Mazen his family
and to meet with my daughter Gabriela
and so hopeful that we're gonna head
over so I think she's done a drawing for
him hasn't she she has indeed she has
indeed she's done a picture of her and
him and her his four-year-old daughter
and so yes she said it was framed by the
family and hopefully hopefully you like
it I can't believe it's a year ago that
we were having these conversations and
we're still in the same position your
level of frustration and stress must be
beyond calculable
yeah I mean no you're right it's kind of
a second time lucky for us at this point
we're hoping that this foreign secretary
visitor is able to unlock in a way that
then last year we were we were
all the television all the time I'm
hoping that Boris Johnson could unlock
things in the end it didn't work out
I've been up and down certainly I have
to say I am pleased that the Foreign
Secretary was very clear in New York
when when we spoke to you them and
there's been very clear again today in
Tehran and but we'll need to wait to see
what the reaction is and in foreign
office of Isis to be more cautious than
I've been all perhaps even he's being so
I mean I'm hopeful that he is clear this
has gone on for too long
this is unacceptable and and it is time
for this to be over and you know if
we're lucky and adenine will go back for
Christmas and back in time for her 40th
birthday she was out to 72 hours wasn't
she what went wrong so I don't know what
went wrong
yeah certainly we were a little bit
surprised that she was allowed out and
it was great that she was not out and
then we were we were I'm astonished that
she was brought back in and after 72
hours which and was almost unheard of
and and what went along afterwards is
that you know she then collapsed and
it's been a very tough time for her
since so I've been very clear publicly
but said upon closed doors with with
both governments that listen we don't
want that again that just felt like a
big cruel manipulation and it you know
it feels like there are divisions and
the Iranian side and the different parts
of any regime pull in different
directions and partly what was happening
there was was mixed signals but it you
know it comes at a real human cost and
and you know we have to be quite careful
with nothing these days one of the
concerns as we said in the introduction
there it is is the anxiety that nothing
potentially is being used as a political
pawn yeah there's no potentially about
it I mean we've had messages going back
two years saying that that she's being
held and if the British government makes
the agreement she'll be released and
it's not just nothing there are others
who being held there
a number of British Iranians but number
from other countries and it's not you
know that the Iranian government is in
control of this this is the
Revolutionary Guard but it is something
that it needs to be said clearly that
listen if we want to have a normal
relationship with around then they can't
they can't hold innocent people in this
way it's just it's just wrong
do you feel that the fact that President
Trump decided that he wanted to pull out
of the Iranian nuclear deal had any
impact on those that were being held
against their will
foreigners being held against their will
in the country look I think there's a
big context isn't there and there's a
way in which our story is just a family
story and there's a way in which we
wrapped up in in in much bigger politics
and there's a way in which those changes
in the bigger politics affects us so
it's no accident I'm sure that Nazneen
was taken soon after the nuclear deal
came into force it's you know clearly
been the case that since I'm that
nuclear deal has become under a lot of
strain and that there have been
different tensions in Iran and and
between Iran and the West and that place
too in different ways for the British
families it place or in different ways
for the other families the Americans and
the Europeans as as I see things it
looks to me like you know we've been
stuck for a long time and you know
softly-softly approaches hadn't really
worked and I am grateful at the Foreign
Secretary being a lot more strident but
but of course there's a risk and there
is a risk as to how it goes and and Iran
is is a volatile place at the moment
and I mean not the UK isn't in its own
way and so we'll we'll need to see how
things go and what the reactions are
these statements how you doing yeah I
mean it's today's actually I'm very
pleased with the the the way the pharma
sector is conducted this visit and we'll
see you see the response so it's up and
down for me and I'm glad that that he's
out there I'm glad that he's making the
efforts particularly given all that's
going on and yeah let's let's hope it
leads somewhere I'm sure he'll be in
touch in the fullness of time it's good
to talk to you thank you very much
indeed let's hope that you have that
Christmas present that you've both been
waiting for so long appreciate it thank
you thank you